vos connaissances indispensables et
nécessaires pour le socle national il ya
une espèce de ségrégation culturel et
osons poser les mots ne soyons pas
extrêmement dubout bien le parlant pas
en catimini
n'ayant pas de nom de quoi il ya une
sédation nos artistes aussi méritants et
talentueux qu'ils sont sont encore
enfermées dans des cases une casse
exotique une casserole chlorhydrique une
casse mais vraiment se défoncer
d'ailleurs et de là-bas au delà des mers
voilà cette unité nationale elle ne
s'affirme pas elle ne se confirme pas
elle ne se manifeste pas de la
manifestation behiels de l'accès aux
lieux de culture de l'accès aux médias à
tous les médias a pas seulement des
médias dits spécialisés aux locaux mais
des médias nationaux
nous sommes encore en kart et nous
sommes encore confiné et là nous avons
encore un travail à accomplir
nous sommes obligés lorsque nous
travaillons parce que nous faisons des
projets de conquérir des lieux
républicain c'est totalement
anticonstitutionnelle parce que la
république n'était pas une et
indivisible
j'ai voulu construire avec les équipes
un projet qui puisse être et on dit on
n'a pas réussi
nous sommes seulement cinq jours au
musée de l'homme on n'a pas réussi
l'exposition ces deux mois salons
littéraires sont moins week-end on n'a
pas réussi mais on a déjà essayé de
franchir un palier à tout petit j'espère
après ça ouvrirait une boîte de pandore
et ça nous permettra encore d'aller plus
loin
j'ai voulu encore si on le troisième le
conquérir d'autres lieux d'eliokem n'est
pas spécialement habitué à voir voile
accueillir ce type de public
avant cette manifestation eh bien oui là
encore il fallait continuer cette
conquête de certains espaces qu'ils
soient accessibles à tous alors qu'est
ce que ça donne du public évidemment
qu'ils viennent nombreux
il ne faut pas que notre action cela
donc nous soyons nombreux
il faut que ça soit une manifestation de
la magnificence des autres maires alors
évidemment j'attends que le public soit
extrêmement nombreux et je sais qu'il le
sera et je le remercie d'avancé qu'il y
ait un engouement et une fièvre
je voudrais que nous puissions était
seul et le mois de mars n'ont pas